auch 2009 10 stand der nato gipfel unter
keinem besonders guten stern
diesmal war es allerdings nicht
us-präsident trump der die mitglieder
von und sicherte
es waren frankreichs präsident makro der
die allianz im vorfeld als hirntot
bezeichnete und der türkische präsident
erdogan der drohte abstimmungen zu
blockieren heute in vechta kompakt ist
die natur hier eigentlich wollte man das
70 jährige jubiläum begehen und
zuversicht wecken durch absetzt davon
gab es wahrlich genug zu besprechen auf
diesen nato gipfel
neben makros kritischen äußerungen weis
fallen die türkei die eigenmächtig in
nordsyrien einmarschierte und von allen
partnern forderte die kurdische jpg als
terror organisation einzustufen
die baltischen staaten polen und
rumänien wiederum sind verunsichert ob
sie tatsächlich im fall des falles gegen
eine russische intervention auf die
volle unterstützung aller partner zählen
können und die eu ist bestrebt
sicherheit und verteidigung vermehrt auf
ihre agenda zu setzen
betrachtet man daher die entwicklung der
letzten jahre so waren auf diesem gipfel
vor allem drei fragen zu beantworten
erstens wie stark ist der innere
zusammenhalt der nato der viel zitierte
artikel 5 der die gegenseitige
beistandspflicht festlegt wurde ja schon
in frage gestellt zweitens wie belastbar
sind die transatlantischen beziehungen
beim gipfel 2018 gab es dazu
weitreichende beschlüsse die ein
verstärktes us-engagement in europa
vorsehen und drittens gibt es hinweise
auf eine optimierte abstimmung der
verteidigungsanstrengungen von nato und
eu
damit könnte die effektivität deutlich
gesteigert werden
zur frage des zusammenhalts die
bereitschaft zur kollektiven
verteidigung erfordert gleiche
strategische interessen und ein
gemeinsames betroffen sind finden
allerdings sehen die in westlichen und
südlichen nato-staaten den nahen und
mittleren osten sowie nordafrika als
gefährlichste regel
während die mitglieder im osten für
russische aggression warnen
die türkei wiederum hat zwar die gipfel
erklärung unterzeichnet dürfte jedoch
mit der annäherung an russland weiterhin
einen sonderweg verfolgen
man ist aber bemüht den zusammenhalt zu
festigen so steigen wie von den usa
gefordert die verteidigungsbudgets
deutschland zahlt künftig mit 16,3 den
gleichen betrag in das nato budget ein
wie die usa und das weltall wurde zum
gemeinsamen einsatzgebiete erklärt
erstmals wird chinas aufstieg als
sicherheitspolitische herausforderungen
angesprochen
während russland unverändert als größte
militärische bedrohung gilt zum
transatlantischen verhältnis es dürfte
mittlerweile auf beiden seiten des
atlantiks klar sein das trotz aller
differenzen die zusammenarbeit im
sicherheitsbereich von gegenseitigen
nutzen bleibt den usa kann nicht gedient
sein wenn sich unsicherheit in europa
verbreitet und die europäischen
nato-staaten wissen dass sie weiterhin
auf den schutzschirm der usa angewiesen
sind
die kritik der usa richtet sich daher
primär gegen die mandeln
verteidigungsanstrengungen der
europäischen partner und nicht gegen das
bündnis haben sich die abermalige
bekräftigung des artikels 5 bringt das
zum ausdruck tweets des us-präsidenten
dürfen somit nicht überbewertet werden
die beim gipfel 2018 beschlossene
verfügbarkeit von 30 meganisi batterien
30 kampf geschlagen sowie von 30
kriegsschiffen binnen 30 tagen soll ab
2020 gegeben sein
zur abstimmung zwischen nato und eu
angesichts der herben kritik des
französischen präsidenten werde zu
hoffen gewesen dass die zusammenarbeit
von nato und eu auf die tagesordnung
kommt das war aber nicht der fall
in der abschlusserklärung findet sich
lediglich der passus dass die nato eu
kooperation beispiellose fortschritte
mache
allerdings wurde auf vorschlag
deutschlands und frankreichs in
reflexionsprozess beschlossen der
vorschläge für die zukünftige
strategische ausrichtung der allianz
erarbeiten soll
nachdem sich die eu verstärkt in
richtung
die heizung und verteidigungs union
entwickelt wäre es dringend erforderlich
die zusammenarbeit noch intensiver voran
zu treiben
auch österreich ist hier als eu-mitglied
gefordert wenn europa dabei an formaten
selbständigkeit gewinnt sollte das auch
im interesse der usa sein
denn die rolle eines juniorpartners ist
überholt mit deutschlands kanzlerin
merkel gegenüber präsident trump
anmerkte
und nicht zu vergessen china und
russland waren natürlich aufmerksame
zaungäste des gipfels denn moskau möchte
wissen wie sich das nato gefüge
entwickelt und wie dessen schlagkraft
einzuschätzen ist und peking beobachtet
aufmerksam in welchen regionen und
bereichen sich die nato engagieren wird
und welche probleme damit verbunden sein
könnten eine abschluss bemerkung der
nato gipfel in london hat wieder gezeigt
dass ihre mitglieder bemüht sind das
gemeinsame sicherheit streben in den
vordergrund zu stellen und eintracht zu
demonstrieren
angesichts vielfältiger entwicklungen
wird das zunehmend schwieriger
es besteht aber keine veranlassung ihre
existenz in absehbarer zeit in frage zu
stellen